[Music]
we're going to show you how recent
changes in hardware and standards make
one meter location accuracy possible in
some cases as soon as this year I'll
give you a short overview now then Roy
will introduce Wi-Fi round-trip time
technology and standards and show you a
live demo then way we'll explain the
Wi-Fi api's to now return and talk about
new GPS technology and api's at the end
they'll be loading up for the next
session so we'll take questions right
outside that door and will be available
at office hours at 1:30 p.m. today so
it's a great time for location
applications because technology hardware
standards and Android api's are all
evolving simultaneously to enable
accuracy that has not been possible
previously in phones so eventually this
means high accuracy for everyone but
today we want to take you under the hood
of location because we want to give you
the opportunity to get a head start on
the future we also want to highlight the
need to protect and respect the user the
more people who use location the more
people the more careful we and you have
to be will highlight where you must get
user permissions and we'll close with
some guidelines for making great
location apps so where are we today with
indoor location accuracy if you think
you've noticed that your phone seems to
be more accurate when you're inside
shopping malls and office blocks then it
was a few years ago you're not imagining
it with each release of the fused
location provider we have had steady
improvement of the Android algorithms
and machine learning for Wi-Fi locations
there continues to be improvement and
you'll see indoor accuracy of better
than 10 meters but round-trip time is
the technology that will take us to the
1 meter level meanwhile what about GPS
well
terms of GPS accuracy in the open sky
there has been not much change in the
last few years
you're out in the open sky your GPS
accuracy from your phone is 5 meters and
that's been constant but wrong
measurements roar GNSS measurements from
the phones you can now improve on this
and with changes in satellite and
receiver hardware the improvements can
become dramatic now everyone's familiar
with the blue dot but to get the blue
dot you need the location provider of
course and to get location you need
measurements specifically range
measurements from Wi-Fi access points or
from GPS satellites today we'll show you
how one meter measurement accuracy is
available in phones the key technologies
are Wi-Fi round-trip time GPS dual
frequency and carrier phase measurements
and we'll show you how to use accurate
measurements to create accurate location
now if you just want to wait a year or
two this will find its way into the
worldwide ecosystem and the fused
location provider but we want to give
you a chance for a one to two year lead
by taking accurate measurements and
turning them into accurate location we
want to work with you to accelerate the
future to take it and bring it closer to
the present so you might wonder well why
do I need better location accuracy
anyway well let's just look at two
instances where existing apps could use
much better location accuracy so for
indoor routing or navigation of the kind
that you used to in your cars you need
much better accuracy than you have
outdoors you need one meter accuracy
because indoor features like the
distance between cubes or aisles only a
few meters and even for the most loved
outdoor applications such as directions
and specially directions in traffic we
could use higher accuracy than we have
now for example when you came here this
morning in a car you probably had the
time estimated by the average traffic
speed what you really want is the
traffic speed in the lane that you're in
so that you could ask how fast would it
be if I could take the carpool lane they
of course many other use cases and I'll
mention a few before we finish
but the important thing is that we are
sure that you will have many more ideas
than we have
and that's the beauty of the open
Android ecosystem so now here's Roy to
tell you about Wi-Fi round-trip time
thanks Frank and I'm very excited to be
here today to tell you about a new
positioning technology in Android P we
call Wi-Fi round-trip time or RT t
you'll hear me say that acronym a lot
which is basically measuring the time of
flight of RF signals it has the
potential to estimate your indoor
position to an accuracy of one to two
meters now we're going to hit the ground
running today before I tell you about
the details of our TT and we're going to
show you a video of indoor navigation
based powered by OTT and I want to
emphasize first of all that this is not
a product but an internal prototype to
explore the power of the technology and
how it can also be used to support other
context-aware applications this
prototype also showcases some of the
magic that Google could offer to its
employees today so we're gonna roll the
video and what you should keep in mind
if this is a bit like car GPS except
we're working indoors so in a moment
you'll see there's an application it's a
mapping application and we're searching
for a conference room we found that
conference room it's plotted the route
that's the shortest route and now we're
off we're following the route and as I
make progress you can see the route is
turning gray my position from our TT is
the big rage lot and I'm deliberately
making an error here so the system is
rerouting and it's rerouting again if I
get about 20 feet away it starts the
rerouting process and I'm following the
route and you can see the code of flying
by and there and coming in and I've
arrived at my destination conference
room Tefo so that is the power of our TT
and the thing to think about thank you
the thing to think about here is that if
you didn't have 1 to 2 meter accuracy
then when that system rerouted it would
jump potentially between aisles that
were surrounding me and it would be a
terrible user experience so that's why
it's so important to have this kind of
accuracy so before I get into the
details of a Wi-Fi RTT I want to tell
you about how we calculate location
indoors now we use Wi-Fi RSSI which
stands for received strict signal
strength
indication and basically we can
calculate distance as a function of
signal strength now the figure that you
see on the left-hand side here the
access point which is in the center has
a heat map of signal strength the green
is the strongest and the red is the
weakest at the edges and I've placed two
phones on this diagram at the transition
between the weak and the strong
notice that the phone on the right is
further away from the access point than
the phone on the left so say the signal
strength different distance and it's
this variability in distance for signal
strengths that unfortunately makes it
very hard to get accurate our readings
from our SSI on a regular basis but
there are lots of algorithms and tricks
that we can pull to improve this but it
can be improve further and that's where
Wi-Fi RTT comes into place so Wi-Fi RTT
round-trip time it uses time of flight
instead of signal strength it measures
the time it takes to send a packet a
Wi-Fi RF packet from an access point to
a phone and back again and because radio
signals travel at the same speed as
visible light if we multiply the total
time by the speed of light and we divide
by 2 we get distance round-trip time
divided by 2 and we get the range from
the phone to the access point so that's
the basic principle now if you want to
calculate position we have to use a
process called multilateration and more
on that in a minute but the key thing to
think about here is the more ranges you
have the more constraints you get in a
more accurate position you can achieve
and if you can use at least four
ranges than we think you can get
typically an accuracy of one to two
meters in most buildings so why am I
telling you about Wi-Fi RTT today why
not last year or before well what I want
you to take away is that 2018 is the
year of Wi-Fi our RTT in android your
takeaways are that we are releasing a
public API in Android P based on the I
Triple E eight to eleven MC protocol and
furthermore we're also integrating
aspects of this protocol into the fused
location provider which is the main
location API that people use to put
location on a map and anytime there are
our TT access points in the vicinity the
accuracy of that position will be
greater a little bit of history the 82
11 standard was ratified in 2016 the end
of it and in early 2017 the Wi-Fi
Alliance started doing Interop between
silicon vendors to make sure the chips
followed the protocol and that's when we
started doing a lot of work to validate
how it could be integrated into android
and by the fall of this year of course
we will release the API so that all of
you can I have access and build your own
applications around that technology so
now diving into the principles of how
Wi-Fi MTT works
so the ranging process starts with the
standard Wi-Fi scan the phone discovers
the access points which are round and
based on certain bits which is set
inside the beacons and the probe
responses we can figure out which of
those access points are RTT capable and
the phone chooses one of those two range
- and it starts by making a request to
the access point and as a result the
access point will start a ping pong
protocol back the ping is sent to the
phone is called an FTM or fine timing
measurement packet and the pond which
sent back to the access point is an
acknowledgment of that packet the time
stamps are recorded at each end that
each device records them but for the
phone to calculate the total round-trip
time it needs to have all of those time
stamps so the access point sends one
more packet
third message which contains the missing
to the phone then simply calculates the
round-trip time by subtracting the time
stamps from the AP and as its own
turnaround time which all the time
stands that it recorded so that leaves
the time of flight we multiplied by the
speed of light to get distance we divide
by two and we get the range that we care
about now it turns out if you do this
process multiple times you will in fact
get more accuracy and so that's what the
protocol allows for it allows for a
burst in Android we're typically doing a
burst of about eight of these of these
events and as a consequence the system
can calculate statistics so the mean and
the variance which allows us to more
accurately plot a position on a map and
knowing the accuracy also allows us to
calculate a path miraculous well so now
you have ranges how do you get a
position so I just want to give you a
feel for how you go about doing this now
there's lots of different mathematical
approaches and I'm just picking one
because it's relatively easy to explain
but this is where the power of
developers comes in for you to figure
out your own own way to do it so if you
know a phone is at a certain range from
an access point that tells you that it
can be anywhere on the circumference of
a circle of that radius that radius R
and I've written the circle equation for
that circumference on the right hand
side that center x1y1 now if you want to
find a position you've got to constrain
it so if you take four ranges to four
separate access points as I've shown on
the diagram on the right hand side you
then can see that if those ranges were
accurate those circles would intersect
at a single point how do you find that
point programmatically well if you write
those four equations out on the left
hand side you see they're nasty circle
equations it may be difficult but in
fact it's actually very straightforward
you take you pick one of them you
subtract it from all the others and you
end up with a set of line equations the
square terms disappear and those lines
are in fact drawn on this diagram as
well and then it's very easy to find out
where two lines intersect
now there's one problem with what I've
just told you and the problem is
that we're assuming the measurements are
perfect in reality no measurements are
perfect everything has error and there
will be no exact solution to that
equation so let me give you a more
realistic example so here we have
several access points which we've ranged
to and I've exaggerated the problem here
and you can see some of those circles
don't intersect how do you solve that
well in fact you do the same thing as
you did before you subtract the circles
so you get the lines but this time they
don't intersect in a point they
intersect in a polygon in this case it's
a it's a triangle and your phone lies
probably somewhere maximum-likelihood in
the center of that triangle and then we
can apply some college math least
squares solution and get a maximum
likelihood you can find standard
packages which do this on the net you
can then also refine this position
further by repeating this process
particularly as the phone moves and then
you can calculate trajectory and use
filtering techniques like caramel
filters and other things so that's the
basic principles okay now like any new
technology there are challenges and so
we've experienced some of these early on
little robots which you can see on the
right hand side is used by us to measure
the range from the phone which is
carrying to an access point and it
validates that range against the marks
which are on the floor which provide us
with ground truth what we find is that
sometimes there is a constant range
calibration offset may be as much as a
half a meter and sometimes also you see
multipath effects where the non line of
sight path from the access point to the
phone is actually received rather than
the line of sight path that one can be
solved by the vendor using something
called antenna diversity but all of
these things are algorithms which the
vendors are improving and and basically
we need to go through a sort of teething
process of getting rid of these bugs and
Google can help in this process by
providing reference platforms and
reference applications so the vendors
can calibrate their own platforms before
you guys even get to use them which will
be the ideal situation now I've assumed
that you want to start as an early
adopter and start using this API but as
we move into the relatively near future
we expect you
to just use the fuse location provider
because we're going to be putting the
RTG capability into it so at the moment
fuse location provider uses GPS when is
available cell signal strength Wi-Fi
RSSI and also fuses with the onboard
sensors no inertial navigation from
accelerometer and gyro now we're adding
Wi-Fi RTT into that mix and it will
increase the accuracy whenever RTT
capable access points are available
okay so the one other thing to remember
is that when you were doing it yourself
you had to know the position of the
access points in the fused location
provider we will know those positions
automatically for you we'll crowdsource
those positions and so you won't have to
worry about that and that would make
life a lot more a lot easier for you to
write applications okay so now we're
going to take it up a notch and we're
going to give you a live RTG demo in
collaboration some of our colleagues in
Gia so what I have over here on the
podium is is a phone let's bring it back
okay there we go which is running an RTG
system in combination with Google mobile
maps and what we're doing is we're using
a number of access points which are
around the room so you I'm only go you
saw the blue boxes which are on the
slide so these were provided by one of
our partners and you can see them around
the room towards the back on the side
notes a couple in the center over here
now the thing to bear in mind is that
you would this phone because we're just
in a tent would normally receive GPS
signals so we've disabled GPS you're
only using our cheechee with this phone
and and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to walk around the aisles and you
can see on this car that I've already
got a plot of where anger to go so I'm
gonna start moving now and it's like
going towards the corner of the stage
and you should see the blue dot with my
little man inside following me and we of
course we expect an accuracy of 1 to 2
meters and so I'm walking on the aisle
the aisle here is about it's about two
meters across
there abouts and you can see it's very
nicely following within that accuracy I
think the the demo environment has been
very good to us so far so we're going
along and it's a little bit of lag it's
going around the back here and we're
approaching a turnaround point where I'm
going to walk up the aisle and we're
rerouting as I come back to make my path
a little bit shorter and you can see
we're going very nicely it's still well
within the one to two meters and if you
had GPS shown here as well I mean
typically you would be expecting to see
five meters but that's accruals outdoors
and indoors in a typical building you've
only gone it you're only going to have
indoor location technology such as this
so now I'm approaching the corner of the
stage and at this point I'll hand back
over to way thank you very much
thank you good boy he's gonna tell you
about the details of the API
hey thanks alright
what a great demo so now you must be
very good to try round-trip time
rendering yourself
let me walk you through the are TTIP ad
in he to sing how you can add RTG in
your own application so as I mentioned
RTD measures the round-trip time between
two Wi-Fi devices so both your mobile
phone and your access points need to
support either 2000 MC protocol and as
you sell RTD can give you very fine
location down to one meter accuracy so
your application need to declare access
sign location permission and of course
post location and Wi-Fi scan need to be
enabled on the mobile device okay so how
do you know whether your mobile phone
support a cutie in P we ID'd a new
system feature called feature Wi-Fi RTT
so you can simply check whether this is
written true i a mobile device our pixel
phones running p DV 2 and above where's
about RG t so how do you know whether
your access points support our duty as
normal you will need to do a Wi-Fi scan
and get a list of Wi-Fi scan results
each right to sue this needs some work
once a scan results and check whether
this method is 802 11 MC responder
return to this will tell you whether the
access points support our duty so after
you get a list of RTD never deities
simple atom to scan request builder to
build a scan request RTT is done by
Wi-Fi RTG manager which you can simply
get by getting the system serviced Wi-Fi
RTP rendering service okay now we're
ready to start our TV running by sending
the RTD request to the RTP manager with
the rhaenyra darker back our TV will
start
surely RTT text no more than hundreds of
milliseconds and when the finishes you
would get a list of information
including the status RTT Mifare the MAC
address which IP you have just arranged
and also the most importantly the
distance between the mobile phone and
the access point so here is the list of
information you can get from our key
tyranny results you can get the distance
it also gets distance and dimension
which is a sensation from multiple
ranges in multiple FTMs and you can also
get number of attempted FGM measurements
and number of successful moments so the
ratio of successful measurements over
account environments will give you an
idea of how good the Wi-Fi environment
is 43 reindeer okay so I mentioned our
pencil devices were some hierarchy tea
how about access points were beginning
to some exit points supporting lmmse
protocol in production and we are very
excited to let you know Google Wi-Fi
will soon support lmmse protocol yeah
thank you by the end of this year of the
sheriff Wi-Fi we have our TV enabled by
default
and worldwide were also beginning to sin
the deployment of our DDI vs South Korea
is actually leading the development of
our of our TTIP s and of course this is
just the beginning of the long journey
we're very eager to sing a larger
penetration rate of our TVs in upcoming
years with that I'm going to hand over
to Frank to talk about one meter GPS
thank you
okay so let's move to the great outdoors
and speak about GPS I'm going to show
you some basics of GPS just enough to
explain what's new to the satellites and
what's new in the phones and how you can
exploit these changes to get better
location accuracy from GPS when you're
outdoors under open sky so GPS works
like this it sends a code from the
satellite and the code encodes the time
at the satellite the net travels to you
through space and arrives at you and
your GPS receiver will compare that time
with the time in its clock the
difference between those two tells you
how far you are away it's kind of like
you have a tape measure where one ends
at the satellite and you're holding the
school at any moment you can look down
and read a number which is the
difference in these two times if you
move further away you read a bigger
number do you move a little bit closer
you read a smaller number okay
but now the actual GPS tape measure is
kind of special first of all it's really
long
secondly the tick marks occur only every
300 meters because these bits of the
code occur at a rate of one microsecond
so one microsecond times the speed of
light is about 300 meters so this is
like a tape measure where instead of
having all these inches on here you only
have a mark every 300 meters and your
GPS receiver essentially interpolates
between those marks and there's your
five meter accuracy okay but there's
more to it than that
because how does that code get through
space in the first place well it's
carried on a carrier wave radio wave
which for GPS has a wavelength that is
less than twenty centimeters and your
GPS receiver can measure where you are
on this wave and as long as it keeps
tracking it can measure relative motion
with great precision and this is because
it the receiver will measure the face
and as you move that phase will change
but now what about getting your absolute
location the trouble with the carrier
phase ruler if you like is that it's
it's kind of like a ruler with very
precise markings on it but no numbers at
all because one wavelength looks just
like the next so your your receiver can
tell you the phase of the wave you're on
but it doesn't know are you the green
dot or the red dot so how do you solve
that problem well for that you need to
introduce a new concept which is GPS
reference stations so these are GPS
receivers at fixed sites measuring the
same thing at the same time they
communicate that data to you with
well-known algorithms you can combine
this data and over some period of time
you can work out where you are relative
to the reference station with great
precision with this carrier phase
precision now you know where the
reference station is so now you know
where you are with great precision ok so
this concept is not new this has been in
commercial GPS receivers since the 1980s
for surveying hence our a little
surveyor there holding the GPS antenna
on the stick what is new is the
availability of these carrier phase
measurements from phones and dual
frequency measurements in phones right
now all of your smart phones all smart
phones everywhere have GPS or GNSS on
one frequency band only it's known as l1
but there's a new frequency in town it's
called l5 and it's supported by all
these GNSS systems gps Galileo bado ku
CSS and IRNSS and the availability of a
second frequency means that you get much
faster convergence to carry a phase
accuracy if you're doing this kind of
procedure and why well we just went
through the ambiguity that you have on a
single wave well now look what happens
if you introduce a second wave at a
different frequency immediately you can
disambiguate because you could not have
the same phase on that second wave as on
both of those wavelengths so you could
not be on the red dot if you're at the
peak of
B of the red wave and so you can
disambiguate and get much faster
convergence to the very high accuracy
that you want all right so what about
hardware well in the last few months
several companies that produce consumer
GPS chips have announced the
availability of dual frequency l1 l5 GPS
chips both for the automobile market and
for the phone market and these chips are
now being designed into cars and phones
now let's talk about the measurements
themselves and the AP is the the phone
must support the GNSS measurements API
and your app is going to need access
fine location permission and location
needs to be on so these are the basic
requirements so how do you know if a
particular phone supports these
measurements will add a high level you
can just go to a website that we
maintain geo / GNSS tools as part of the
Android developer site and there's just
a table there that lists phones that
support the GNSS measurements and also
which characteristics they support so
it'll tell you which phones support the
measurements and which of those support
the carrier phase measurements
programmatically you do this as follows
you need a method on status changed and
it will return a ninja integer that
tells you the capability of the phone
either if the phone just does not
support the measurements at all or if
they supported but location is off or if
they support it and location is on in
that last case you're good to go so now
let's get into some details of the api's
the most relevant methods for what we're
talking about here are the following
three there's get constellation type
which tells you which of the different
GNSS constellations a particular
satellite belongs to there's get carrier
frequency hertz which tells you whether
you're on the l1 or the l5 band for a
particular signal and then most
importantly there's get accumulated
Delta range meters which is how far
along that wave the receiver has tracked
you since it began tracking the signal
and then there's something else that I
need to explain which is duty cycling
so right now when you're navigating with
your phone and you see the blue dot
moving along for example when maybe when
you're navigated here this morning you
might think that the GPS is on
continuously and it's actually not
what's happening in the phone is that
GPS will by default be on for a fraction
of a second and then off for the
remaining fraction of a second and then
repeat and this is to save battery so
you perceived that the GPS is on all the
time because the blue dot will move
along continually but actually it's duty
cycling internally now for this carrier
phase processing you have to continually
track the carrier wave because remember
the carrier wave is the ruler with no
numbers on it so if the GPS was on and
your receiver measured your phase and
you get the data from the reference
station you'd start processing if the
GPS then goes off for a fraction of a
second well now you've lost where you
were it'll start again you'll reacquire
you'll be a different phase on the react
position you'll start again well you'll
never solve the problem back right you
need the tape measure to stay out and
you need to process and to do that you
need to disable duty cycling and you can
do that in Android P with a developer
option which I'll talk about some more
in a minute okay so now add some details
of the API what I've shown here on the
right is a screen shot of an application
that we've put out it's called GNSS
logger and this is enables you to log
the raw measurements in the phone now
the nice thing about this app is it's a
reference app the the code is open
source and available to you on github so
when you build your app please you could
make use of our code and when you do
build an app that needs role measurement
you will need the Android location
manager API with the method register
GNSS measurements callback and this
method requires you to pass it a GNSS
measurements event callback shown here
you construct this callback and then
override the method on status changed
and that will give you the integers
status that we discussed to tell you if
measurements are supported if they are
you then override the method on Jia's on
GNSS measurements received and this
allows you to receive a GNSS measurement
event
every epoch for example every second and
this event gives you the values we've
been talking about constellation type
carrier frequency and accumulated Delta
range now for duty cycling that's a
developer option so you access that
through the developer page on your phone
as you see there on P and this allows
you to disable the duty cycling now keep
in mind this introduces a trade-off
between getting the continuous
measurements and battery life there will
be an impact on battery life how much
well even when GPS is on continually
it'll use less than 20% of the power
that screen on users so that gives you a
feel for the magnitude now this is a
developer option precisely because it's
a trade-off in in battery life and we're
very concerned about maximizing battery
life but if you and we together can
prove that there's value in this option
and people want it then it will be
upgraded to a fully supported API in the
future so here's a block diagram that
shows the basic architecture that we
expect if you implement an app for high
accuracy than the bottom of the block
diagram on the Left you've got the GPS
GNSS chip the GNSS measurements come up
through the api's we've just described
and then your app lives at the top in
the application layer you're going to
need access to a reference network to
get the data that the reference stations
are tracking they are publicly available
a reference networks I've listed one
down the bottom the International GNSS
service IGS org and you can get data
from them free then you need to process
that data in some kind of position
library and that does all this carrier
phase processing and that too is
available as open source code there's
another example down there our TK Lib
org has an open source package for
precise positioning and then you're good
to go now I mentioned that dual
frequency gives you much faster
convergence to the high accuracy but you
don't have to wait until the dual
frequency phones come out you can start
doing this with single frequency phones
and here's an example of someone who's
already done that this
is an app created by the French Space
Agency and they they're doing exactly
what we show on the block diagram on the
left and they're achieving sub-meter
accuracy after a few minutes of
convergence here's some more external
analysis that's been done in a similar
way this is from a paper called
positioning with Android GNSS this is
using one of those chips that I showed
you the chip that goes in cell phones
that does dual frequency and what's been
shown here is the cumulative results
over many different starts of the GPS
and what you see is that most of the
time the accuracy is better than a meter
you see that on the vertical axis which
is 0 to 1 meters the accuracy gets to
better than a meter in less than one
minute and then continues to converge as
long as the phone continues to track
that carrier phase continuously here's a
another similar but different paper this
is using one of the chips that's meant
for cars and so this was tested in a car
driving around that track there and what
the plot here is showing is the accuracy
after the initial convergence while the
car was driving so you see with GNSS
alone the accuracy is 1 to 2 meters and
with this carrier phase processing it's
at a couple of decimeters so for you to
build this what are you going to need
well of course you need the device
location to be enabled and your app has
to have location permissions so that's
going to come from the user you need the
basic GNSS measurements that's been
available since Android n you also need
this continuous carrier phase I've been
talking about and that's available in P
with the developer option it would be
nice to have dual frequency for fast
convergence and that's coming soon you
need a reference network such as the one
I already mentioned there are also
commercial reference networks out there
and commercially available software to
do the same thing but I recommend you
start with a free stuff and go from
there and then finally there's the app
from you so in summary everything we've
been showing you here we have indoor and
outdoor technology that's been evolving
kind of in parallel in each case we have
a new technology and Android P gives you
something to ax
let's talk about indoors again the new
technology is Wi-Fi round-trip time and
round-trip time enabled access point we
give you public API to access these
measurements but you need access point
infrastructure so this is where some of
you can do this this year because if you
have a customer who owns or controls a
venue they can upgrade their access
points sometimes just a firmware upgrade
and then you have the infrastructure
Android P comes out later this year and
you can implement something like what
Reuters demoed and have indoor
navigation or many other apps for
example someone goes in a store where's
the milk you can make the world a better
place for all of us by saving us from
the tyranny of having to ask directions
from strangers okay
and if you if you're not one of those
people who has access to this now in a
few years the infrastructure will
naturally evolve as access points
upgrade to Roger time and this will be
available from fused location provider
as Roy said now outdoors okay for this
carrier phase process they can it's not
just outdoors but outdoors with open sky
and what do you need dual frequency and
continuous carrier phase and we give you
the API and the developer option to make
use of that you will need reference
station access as I mentioned and then
applicate well what can you do outdoors
with open sky well we already mentioned
the traffic example and there's many
other examples that readily come to mind
where existing GPS accuracy doesn't cut
it for example geocaching where people
go look for treasures would be nice to
have one meter accuracy precision sports
monitoring imagine a snowboarder who
wants to measure her tracks very
precisely after the fact five meters not
good enough one meter would be great
speaking of sports they're more and more
drone apps where you kind of follow me
and the drone will fly along and video
you well it'd be nice if the videos you
and not the person next door to you and
so on I'm sure there are hundreds of
apps and you're probably thinking of
some right now and that's the whole
point we want you to do that and you and
ask together bend the arc of Technology
history closer to the present and I'm
really looking forward to next year to
see some of you back here and see what
you've created and so finally I want to
leave you with a couple of pointers when
you build location apps please build
great location apps you must have user
trust please provide the user with
transparency and control you're gonna
have to ask for location permissions for
this explain to them what you're doing
how it benefits them when things go
wrong make your app recover gracefully
if these measurements are unavailable
for some moment or something goes wrong
you can fall back to fused location
provider location so think about that
and finally respect the battery life
trade-offs that we've discussed so I
must remind you to fill out your surveys
please at that site and as I mentioned
will be available outside the door here
for any questions or so from all three
of us thank you
[Music]